[موسيقى]
يطلق الفتيه صفارات وهتافاتهم في الشوارع
بوجه قوات مكافحه الشغب قرب ميدان التحرير
ان معانده الاطفال للسلطات ليس امرا غريبا
مقارنه مع الجيل الاكبر سنا لكن المصريين
اطفوا لمستهم
عليها وكانت الشرطه مصدرا للخوف على مر
عقود مضت في تاريخ الدوله لكن الثوره
والفوضى التي تبعتها غيرتها جميع المفاهيم
بلط
بلطجيه اه بلطجيه بس ايام زمان كان مفروض
نحترم الشرطه صح اه كنا نحترمهم و دلوقتي
بس دلوقت الكرامه بتاعتهم راحت ووفقا
للارقام الرسميه تكون فئه الشباب من عمر
18 عاما الى 29 عاما ربع الشعب المصري كما
ان نصف الشعب يواجه الفقر ومع جمود الوضع
الاقتصادي على حاله اشتكى الكثيرون من
الوض شاب النهارده عايز النهارده يشتغل مش
لاقي شغل النهارده عشان تطلع تشتغل هتطلع
تشتغل ورا بنا
مش بصفه مجلس جابه انقاذ او حزب كذا او
وكذا لا انا بتكلم على اني سائر انا مافيش
حد بيمثلني انا بمثل نفسي لان كل اللي
بيمثلني معلش عايزين كرسي بس والاحزاب
كلها عايزه كراسي بس كل حاجه انتخابات
انتخابات في ثوره يبقى مافيش
[موسيقى]
انتخابات يمكن للشرطه ان تفرق المتظاهرين
ويمكنها ان تدفعهم للرجوع الى الوراء لكن
لا يمكنها ابعادهم لا يتوقفون امام
الجدران الفاصله ولا يهربون من الغازات
المسيله للدموع
كان القاده السياسيون يزورون ميدان
التحرير خلال فتره الثوره لكن الوضع الان
يعتبر خطرا للغايه توقف رجال السياسه عن
النزول الى الشارع والصبيه المنتشرون في
الشوارع لا يطلبون منهم شيئا ورغم ان
الشباب الهموا الثوره لكن القياده تبقى
للجيل الاكبر سنا فالاشخاص الظاهرون في
المؤتمرات الصحفيه اكثرهم من كبار السن
تاركين الخيار الوحيد امام الشباب
المنفصلين عن السلطه التوجه الى حرب
الشوارع للتعبير عن اصواتهم الغاضبه بحسب
الباحث عمر عبد الرحمن ان شعورهم
بالاغتراب داخل اوطانهم ازداد بعد نهايه
الثوره لان هذه الثوره بنظرهم ادت الى
اقصائهم بشكل
اكبر وتبقى الحجاره الطريقه الوحيده التي
يمكنها ان تثبت
وجودهم الله